joining me now is Congressman Byron
Donalds Congressman it's great to see
you tonight you know they all got mad at
me last week when I said you know it's
time to step aside your future in
politics is not over they're both you
know still pretty young and could both
do a lot but uh now we have DeSantis
doing the right thing but Haley has a
series of Big Ticket fundraisers
scheduled what does that tell
you what it tells me is Laura you have a
lot of donors who haven't seen the
riding on the wall but I'm up here in
Northern New Hampshire right now they
just got done with the national anthem
and I'm going to tell you the fever for
Donald Trump is real that's what
Republican voters want all across our
country the line outside and 20° weather
proves it and the donors need to come
face the facts and face the reality that
the thing that's going to save this
nation is an America First agenda and
Donald Trump's going to deliver it well
uh Congressman you're in New Hampshire
you feel the energy um but some of the
so-called never trumpers who used to
work in the Trump Administration and if
they could they would come crawling back
now but they can't because they're
actually hosts of The View
watch there's some sexism we haven't
talked about Ronda santis actually
intellectually knows that Nikki Haley is
more qualified and more fit to be the
GOP nominee he's a Harvard grad he's a
Yale undergrad he served in the Navy he
knows Donald Trump is not better than
her congressman is sexism the reason
Nikki Haley isn't winning only the
sheriff no it's not it's about the
agenda and it's about what the American
people have seen Donald Trump has done
this job Laura we've talked about that
many many times and Nikki Haley does
represent the Old Guard in the old way
in the Republican party that's how she
came up that's how she governed in South
Carolina the voters in our country
Republican voters in our country do not
want that they are tired of business as
usual in Washington DC and frankly in a
lot of state capitals in our country
what they want is an agenda that speaks
for them that speaks to them that
demonstrates that our our government is
serious about doing everything of by and
for the people not for businesses not
for foreign Nationals not for
international globalist communities but
for the American people first and
foremost that's what they want and
that's what they're going to get
Congressman I'm just glad that you have
a really loud voice given where you're
standing right now thank you very much
for joining us and have fun out there my
friend hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else